bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin l'audition par la commission des
finances de didier migaud le premier
président de la cour des comptes
il est entendu sur leur rapport annuel
qui a été rendu public le 12 février
c'est le premier à avoir affirmé que
l'objectif du gouvernement de ramener le
déficit public à 3% du pib fin 2013
aurait peu de chances de se réaliser
et depuis bruxelles l'a estimée à 3,7
pour cent pour cette année même chose du
côté de la prévision de la croissance
évaluée à 0,8 pour cent cette année elle
aussi enterré résultat pour la cour des
comptes
l'état doit revoir sa copie et trouver
de nouvelles économies
tous les membres du gouvernement se
réunissent d'ailleurs ce matin pour un
déjeuner économique à matignon auprès de
jean-marc ayrault
objectif faire le bilan de la situation
budgétaire et des finances publiques au
regard notamment de l'emploi de
l'investissement et de la croissance
d'ici à la fin de la semaine prochaine
ils doivent recevoir leur lettre de
cadrage qui fixe leurs orientations en
matière de dépenses pour didier migaud
en tout cas la priorité doit être porté
sur la maîtrise des dépenses
il préconise également une fiscalisation
des allocations familiales
depuis donc direction la salle
clemenceau pour l'audition de didier
migaud le premier président de la cour
des comptes très bonne matinée à tous
sur public sénat
monsieur le premier président mesdames
et messieurs les présidents de chambre
et et et conseillers m
mes chers collègues nous allons entamer
une audition qui s'annonce
particulièrement intéressante et tout
récemment le 13 février
le premier président est venu
solennellement mais substantiellement
présenter et le rapport public de cette
année mais il se trouve que l'hémicycle
était et était bien remplie n'est ce pas
ce qui n'était pas forcément le cas à ce
point les années précédentes c'est sans
doute un signe des temps
c'est sans doute aussi le signe de
l'intérêt du débat qui suivait mais mais
je crois qu'il faut dire que le rapport
public remis en ce début d'année 2013 un
impact
tout à fait tout à fait réelle et que la
la cour des comptes est là la
juridiction financière et en même temps
le grand auditeurs de l'état s'ils
jouent ainsi m'exprimer et qui est
susceptible de poser de vraies questions
de faire vivre les problématiques de les
approfondir et de faire tout cela en
lien étroit avec le pouvoir législatif
et ce matin nous avons prévu une séance
interactive puisque la présentation
globale déjà eu lieu mais au cours de
cette présentation globale
le format de la séance ne permettait pas
de nombreuses expressions donc nous
souhaiterions monsieur le premier
président est qu'à l'issue d'une
présentation liminaire brève nous
puissions ensuite entré dans
les sujets que nous avons sélectionnés
en concertation entre nous ceci
permettant au rapporteur général bien
sûr mais aussi aux différents
rapporteurs spéciaux concernés par ces
sujets de vous questionner puis aux
membres de la commission de de
s'exprimer à leur tour et est de vous
interroger en toute liberté
alors je précise que cette séance de la
commission des finances est ce le cas où
une commission de la sociale non non non
non c'est une pure séance de la
commission des finances pardonnez moi
mais qui est retransmise par nos par nos
images d'où le fait que nous siégions en
salle clémenceau et donc monsieur le
premier président vous allez intervenir
au cours de ce propos liminaires sur
deux thèmes les aspects globaux des des
finances publiques et de la gestion de
l'art de la convergence de la
consolidation budgétaire et d'autre part
les aspects relatifs aux finances des
départements
j'ai leleu et est ensuite et après que
nous ayons pu nous livrer un tour
d'horizon sur ces deux aspects nous
aborderons plusieurs sujets
sectorielle questions sur la culture
l'écologie le financement du logement
nos excellents débitants de tabac en
particulier et vous avez à vos côtés et
lé président de la première chambre
raoul briet de la deuxième chambre
gilles pierre lévy de la troisième
chambre patrick le fin de la 5ème
chambre anne froment-meurice de la 7e
chambre
evelyne ratte et votre rapporteur
général puisque la cour des comptes est
une institution qui a aussi un
rapporteur général ce qui la rend
naturellement proche de nous et je
voudrais monsieur le président en vous
demandant de bien vouloir prendre la
parole sur les aspects globaux des
finances publiques vous demander si la
contrainte des 3% de déficit nominal
doit à votre avis être mises au placard
ou si cette contrainte doit continuer à
être gérés simultanément avec celle du
solde structurel notion macroéconomiques
plus complexe - mobilisatrice moins
facile à expliquer et à l'opinion
publique mais résultant du tcg et de la
loi organique et que le parlement a
récemment adopté donc c'est le premier
aspect sur lequel certainement vous vous
exprimerez et j'y ajouterai j'en
resterai là un second point
la loi organique à laquelle je faisais
allusion à créer un haut conseil des
finances publiques
ce haut conseil va devoir exercer ses
responsabilités
vous en serez aussi le président et il
serait utile que vous nous disiez ce que
nous pouvons attendre de ce haut conseil
des finances publiques
doit-il se borner à donner une simple
appréciation sur la sincérité et la
fiabilité des prévisions du gouvernement
peut-il un jour aller jusqu à formuler
des recommandations pour retenir
éventuellement d'autres hypothèses et
prévisions et que celle proposée par
l'éxécutif quels seront les moyens dont
disposera ce haut conseil pour faire
face à des missions aussi évolutive
serait utile que vous nous en parler que
nous des voiliers ou le vient peu le
voile sur surtout cela sachant que cette
instance va être paritaires et que vous
avez procédé il y a quelques jours avec
de nombreux témoins et le procès verbal
en fait foi
or au tirage au sort qui affecte des
hommes et des femmes aux différentes
autorités de nomination
c'était une première et les choses
naturellement ont été faites dans les
formes sur le premier président vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
j'ai déjà eu le plaisir vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président de
remettre le rapport en séance publique
le 13 février dernier
et à cette occasion j'en avais résumé
les principaux
élément devant vous qui pouvaient être
retirées des 45 sujet qui composent ce
rapport public annuel de la cour d'eau
comme vous le suggérez je ne vais pas
vous le résumé à nouveau préférant plus
directement répondre aux questions que
vous avez souhaité nous nous poser et je
suis entouré comme vous l'avez précisé
de quelques présidents de deux chambres
qui m'accompagne ainsi que de jean
philippe vaka qui week est là sur une
droite qui préside la formation inter
juridiction sur les finances locales que
j'avais souhaité mettre en place il y a
maintenant deux ans alors comme vous le
savez les sujets qui sont traités par la
cour dans son rapport public annuel
s'adresse aux décideurs publics sur à
vous-même ou citoyen également nous nous
réjouissons de deux de cette possibilité
de pouvoir échanger avec avec vous qui
décidez en dernier ressort alors à
partir des constats que nous faisons
nous souhaitons être le plus utile
possible plus constructive d'où un
certain nombre de recommandations que
nous pouvons faire à partir de nos
constats c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous
avez souhaité puisque pendant très
longtemps la cour ne faisait pas de
recommandations à partir de ces constats
et c'est le législateur qui avait
souhaité que nous puissions formulé un
certain nombre de pistes ou de
recommandations étant entendu que nous
ne faisons à notre place et que le
dernier mot appartient bien évidemment
aux décideurs politiques
vous êtes alors bien évidemment la
situation des finances publiques est
traité dans ce dans ce rapport donc je
peux commencer à répondre à vous à vos
questions nous avons pu préciser que le
redressement des comptes avait été
engagée en 2011 qui s'était poursuivie
en 2012 avec un effort structurel
important comme un effort structurel
important et est effectivement prévue
dans la loi de finances initiale pour
2013 sur 2012 ça représente un effort
il faut remonter aux années 94 et 96
pour avoir un tel effort structurel
donc ça montre que une prise de
conscience a eu lieu et en ce qui
concerne l'effort structurel prévu pour
il est au tour de la ville pour cent de
piles
c'est un effort sans précédent si les
réaliser effectivement tel qu'il est
prévu
effectivement nous avons
précisé que l'objectif de déficit
effectifs de 3% n'avait que peu de
chances d'être atteint à partir d'un
constat que nous faisons c'est à dire
des hypothèses de croissance qui peuvent
ne pas correspondre à la réalité de la
croissance sur l'année 2013 et à partir
du moment où il n'ya pas de 0,8 de
croissance il peut y avoir autant de
milliards en moins tout au moins
quelques milliards en moins en ce qui
concerne les recettes prévues pili agir
viendrait forcément tout à l'heure à
partir de vos questions d'autres
incertitudes sur également les recettes
comme sur les dépenses alors c'est pas
pour cela que nous proposons pour
reprendre votre expression monsieur le
président une mise au placard de la
notion de déficit effectif cela dit nous
disons qu'à partir du moment où le
dernier traité européen la dernière loi
organique a mis en avant ce que l'on
appelle le déficit structurel et
l'effort structurel
nous avons exprimé le souhait que les
responsables politiques au niveau
européen puisse je dirais préciser la
part qui leur revient d'accorder à ces
notions de déficit structurel et de
déficits effectif si l'un doit
l'emporter sur l'autre il n'appartient
pas à la cour de le dire le déficit
effectif reste quelque chose qui peut
être important à partir du moment où ce
déficit effectifs nourrit d'une certaine
façon la dette et l'endettement
mais il est intéressant aussi de
raisonner indépendamment du conjoncture
et de pouvoir prendre en considération
le déficit structurel calcul est donc
indépendamment de la conjoncture et
l'effort
structurel il vous appartient une fois
de plus de préciser le poids
rétrospective qu'il importe de donner à
ces critères ce que nous nous disons
c'est compte tenu de l'effort structurel
envisagée en 2013 et à partir du constat
que nous faisons sur l'objectif de 3%
qui peut ne pas être atteint la course
est vrai ne recommande pas des mesures
supplémentaires pour atteindre à tout
prix cet objectif de 3% de déficit
effectif elle précise en revanche qu'il
est très important que l'effort
structurel prévu soit effectivement
concrétisé et mises en oeuvre
d'où la nécessité de lever quelques
incertitudes tant sur les recettes que
sur les dépenses pour pouvoir réaliser
cet effort structurel
voilà ce que je souhaite vous dire je ne
veux pas être plus longue puisque
j'aurai je pense à répondre à un certain
nombre de vos de vos questions donc
nécessité de de concrétiser respecter
cet effort structurel nécessitait aussi
d'accès l'effort sur la maîtrise de la
dépense
à partir du moment mais je crois que
c'est une des questions que vous
souhaitez poser ou ce jusqu'à présent
l'effort structurel repose
essentiellement sur l'augmentation des
prélèvements obligatoires dans des
proportions très très importante et
qu'il ne nous apparaît nécessaire de
faire en sorte que sur les prochaines
années
cet effort se porte sur la maîtrise de
la dépense et d'une certaine façon
d'ailleurs notre rapport entend
démontrer que cela est possible
à la fois ce rapport public annuel comme
beaucoup de rapports de la cour ce que
nous pouvons constater c'est que la
france à un niveau de dépenses publiques
élevées
quand on compare le niveau de dépense
avec d'autres pays dans le monde
or c'est pas un jugement de valeur que
porte la cour sur ce sur ce constat
c'est un constat que nous faisons c'est
le résultat d'un choix collectifs dans
notre pays pour la dépense publique mais
nous constatons dans le même temps qu'il
y à un niveau de prélèvements
obligatoires qui est aussi parmi les
plus élevés au monde
or ce que les évaluations montrent quand
elles existent et nous considérons
qu'elles sont insuffisantes
insuffisamment nombreuses insuffisamment
étayé mais lorsqu'elles existent elles
montrent que les résultats en termes de
d'efficacité des politiques publiques
lorsqu'ils sont mesurés ne sont pas
toujours en rapport par rapport au
niveau de dépenses et que cela se doit
être une question qui interpelle bien
sûr les responsables politiques que vous
êtes donc nous pensons effectivement que
des marges de manoeuvre peuvent exister
au niveau de la dépense publique sans
remettre en cause ce qui peut constituer
ce qui est appelé le modèle le modèle
français où le modèle social français et
nous avons quelques illustrations dans
le rapport public annuel qui montre que
si l'action publique était davantage
ciblée sur les les
les groupes ou les personnes qui
normalement sont définies comme étant
les cibles de l'action publique
si c'était mieux le cas il y aurait des
économies possibles
ce que l'on peut souvent constaté c'est
une un ciblage insuffisant un pilotage
insuffisant avec du coup un certain
nombre de dépenses publiques qui sont
beaucoup plus importantes j'avais
utilisé cette expression
bon alors que il apparaît nécessaire
d'arroser quelques fleurs en fête
souvent on irrigue on arrose l'ensemble
du jardin bon avec une avec une des
paires pas besoin d'arroser avec de
l'eau potable
certes voilà je vois que vous avez le
souci les économies bon donc
donc voila mais il nous apparaît
possible de traduire davantage ce souci
dans un certain nombre de politiques
publiques en faisant en sorte qu'elles
soient davantage ciblés et davantage
piloter et puis il ya aussi bien sûr des
exemples qui concerne d'autres acteurs
de la dépense publique que l'état à
partir du moment où le redressement des
comptes publics est nécessaire
bien sûr cela concerne tous les acteurs
de la dépense que ce soit l'état mais
également les opérateurs de l'état les
collectivités territoriales si la
situation financière des collectivités
territoriales est plutôt saine et à l'
équilibre compte tenu d'un certain
nombre de règles qui existent
les collectivités territoriales sont
également acteur au niveau de la delà de
la dépense et qu'il y a là aussi un
effort de maîtrise de la dépense à
conduire et c'est la même chose au
niveau de la sécurité sociale voilà pour
répondre à votre question sur le haut
conseil des finances publiques
il va être mise en place prochainement à
la suite de la loi organique que vous
avez adopté il ya le principe de la
parité cette parité ne sera pas totale
à partir du moment où sont membres de
droit du duo on conseille le premier
président de la cour des comptes et le
directeur général de l'insee ce sont des
hommes donc et donc du coup ça rentre
dans la composition du haut conseil à 11
personnes
bonds est donc là la parité s'apprécie
au niveau des magistrats que je devrais
désigné je doit désigner quatre
magistrats deux hommes deux femmes et au
niveau des personnalités qualifiées
nommées par le président de du sénat le
président de l'assemblée les présidents
des commissions des finances de
l'assemblée du sénat et le président du
conseil économique social et
environnemental j'ai procédé au tirage
au sort pour savoir qui du président
du sénat et du président de la
commission des finances du sénat devait
désigner un homme ou une femme
bon même chose pour le président de
l'assemblée en ce qui concerne le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental c'est pour ça que
dans un premier temps la parité on ne
sera pas atteinte au delà même de ce que
j'ai pu dire sur le premier président et
le directeur général de l'insee c'est
que s'agissant du président du conseil
économique social et environnemental
le sort a fait qu'il doit désigner un
homme bon sachant que vous le savez il y
aura un deuxième tirage au sort qui sera
pratiqué puisque vous l'avez souhaité
pour définir la durée des mandats de
chacun puisque ce haut conseil devra
être renouvelé par moitié au bout de
trois ans donc devra être tiré au sort
ceux qui auront un mandat de trois ans
et ceux qui auront un mandat de cinq ans
est entendu qu'il faudra dans l'ensemble
respecté la parité
à partir du moment où le président du
conseil économique social et
environnemental va désigner un homme
cette fois ci il devra désigner une
femme dans trois ans voilà ça c'est le
résultat de votre vote au niveau de la
loi organique
donc les personnalités devraient être
désignés d'ici ce soir par l'ensemble
des autorités de nomination donc je
pense que nous pourrons les rendre
publiques
demain vous devrez au niveau de la
commission des finances du sénat
auditionner les personnalités qui auront
été désignés par le président du sénat
par le président de la commission des
finances
donc je pense que cette audition devrait
intervenir dans la semaine du 10 mahrez
mars au matin 13 mars au matin et une
première réunion de ce haut conseil
devrait intervenir intervenir oui les
mandats 35 ans mais il ya un
renouvellement au bout de 30 mois
le et la première réunion devrait avoir
lieu le 21 mars la mise en place et je
pense que la première saisine du haut
conseil des finances pic sera sur le
projet de programme de stabilité adressé
par le gouvernement français à la
commission européenne d'ici le 30 avril
donc il faudra que d'ici le 15 avril le
haut conseil et pu exprimer son avis sur
ce document vous avez bien précisé dans
le texte organique quels étaient les
missions de ce haut conseil
c'est un organisme indépendant placé
auprès de la cour des comptes et qui a
des missions bien définies c'est à dire
qu'il doit exprimer un avis sur la la
les hypothèses macroéconomiques retenues
par le gouvernement dans son programme
de stabilité qu'il adresse et dans la
confection des lois de finances et de
financement de la sécurité sociale ainsi
que sur les conséquences qu'ils en
tirent sur les questions par exemple
d'élasticité des recettes par rapport
aux hypothèses macroéconomiques retenues
et puis il aura également à donner un
avis sur le respect de la trajectoire
dd de redressement des finances
publiques fois de plus c'est un avis
dans ton tendue qu'à chaque fois il
appartient au parlement d'arrêter
bien évidemment les décisions donc j'ai
tout à fait l'intention de faire en
sorte que le haut conseil exerce
pleinement ses missions
je ne peux pas répondre complètement à
votre question pour savoir exactement de
quelle façon seront formulées les avis
de ceux au conseil puisque le il faut
que j'en parle également aux membres du
duo conseil une fois le plus c'est un
set un avis c'est pas des rapports qui
nous sont demandés donc voilà c'est je
pense qu'il faut que que nous nous en
tenions bien sûr à ce qui nous est
demandé ce qui est déjà pas mal
puis au fil du temps nous aurons à
préciser la façon dont ces avis pourront
être formulées le plus utilement
possible pour que à la fois le
gouvernement et le parlement puisse en
bénéficier au maximum
voilà monsieur le président quelques
propos introductif et puis quelques
premiers éléments de réponse par rapport
aux questions que vous avez souhaité me
poser merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
président indien à présent c'est notre à
porter je n'ai pas de france remarque
qui va intervenir et vous et vous
questionnez certainement merci monsieur
le président fille je dois tout d'abord
de remercier didier migaud pour son
exposé liminaire et et remercié la cour
pour ses volumineux dossier qui nous
sont parvenues et ce rapport très
conséquent
vous savez que les sénateurs sont des
gens scrupuleux donc ils vont
certainement tous ses forces et de lire
par le détail l'ensemble des éléments de
ce rapport et nous avons avec nous les
rapporteurs spéciaux qui auront
certainement pour chacun dans leur
partie des éléments plus précis sur
lesquels ils ont travaillé ou pourront
vous interrogez je m'en tiendrais donc
pour ma part là quelques questions
d'ordre d'ordre général sur le budget et
son exécution
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne le solde
on a un sujet d'interrogation quant à
savoir exactement quelle est la
fourchette précise du déficit public de
2012 au sens du pacte de stabilité
parce que il y a visiblement quelques
incertitudes sur le traitement comptable
de la recapitalisation de dexia et à ce
sujet peut-être pourriez-vous nous
donner votre analyse
dans la mesure où dans votre rapport
vous estimez que si cette opération
était comptabilisée comme une dépense au
sens de la comptabilité nationale
cela aura un impact sur le sol public
2012 pourtant dans le dossier de presse
sur le collectif de fin 2012 le
gouvernement considérait je cite que la
décision d'eurostar sur le traitement en
comptabilité nationale de cette
opération de recapitalisation et sur son
année de rattachement pardon n'est pas
encore connue donc quels sont les
éléments ce président qui permettent
aujourd'hui à la cour de considérer que
le rattachement concernera
nécessairement 2012 puisque nos
informations n'étaient pas tout à fait
cela à ce jour s'agissant des
perspectives pour 2013 s'agissant en
particulier de l'exécution du budget
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
les recettes fiscales et non fiscales
qui seraient les plus susceptibles
d'être inférieurs aux prévisions
pour quelle raison dans quelle
proportion les mondes éclairage utile
elle s'agissant des dépenses
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
indications sur les aléas relatif au
contentieux fiscaux résiduelles et de
financement des mesures nouvelles
alors j'en viens à une question qui a
longuement retenu l'attention des
sénateurs quand on a voté le loi de
finances pour 2013 et qui est la
question de la répartition de l'effort
entre les recettes et les dépenses pour
parce que vous considérez dans le
rapport je cite que l'effort structurel
pour 2013 est déséquilibré il repose
pour moins de 25% sur la maîtrise des
dépenses et pour plus de 75% sur la
hausse des prélèvements obligatoires et
facilitations repose donc trop peu sur
les dépenses alors le bien fondé de
économique de cette affirmation à mes
yeux ne va pas de soi car les
estimations économétriques habituelles
notamment le modèle mésanges du trésor
le suggère que si à long terme une
réduction de dépenses de réduit pas le
pib contrairement à une augmentation de
recettes à court terme c'est le
contraire dans ces conditions la
stratégie du gouvernement consistant à
faire porter principalement l'effort sur
les dépenses en 2013 2017 mais surtout
sur les recettes en 2013 année où la
croissance devrait être nulle part est
adapté puisque si la croissance est une
préoccupation
il faut chercher l'effet de levier le
plus pertinent et l'effet de levier
et d'une dans l'accroissement de
recettes sans l'odieux de l'économétrie
en vigueur aujourd'hui j'aurais
clairement reconnu ça semble être
préférable à court terme
donc la cour des comptes s'appuie-t-elle
sur des travaux économétriques pour
contester cette stratégie faire porter
l'effort essentiellement sur les
dépenses en 2013 ne susciteraient t-il
pas inutilement une croissance négative
si on peut dire rendre encore plus
difficile la réduction du déficit est ce
que les faits n'auraient pas été plus
récessif si on devait procéder selon les
préconisations implicite qui figurent
dans cette analyse qui est fait toujours
les pins dans la chambre et aux fonds
qu'elles puissent vous semblent les plus
prometteuses en termes d'économies sur
les dépenses publiques peut-être
pourriez-vous éclairer notre commission
qui a bien besoin
sur ce sujet qui va nous occuper
longuement les mois qui viennent deux
points de vue les plus enrichissants
possible donc si vous pouvez vous nous
donner quelques indications ne saurions
preneur aux lames ce président a bien
quelques éléments questionnement sur les
considérations générales
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
général et je suggère monsieur le
premier président mes chers collègues
pour que autant possible tous ceux parmi
nous qui souhaitent pouvoir s'exprimer
puisse le faire et que
puisqu'à présent intervenir et les
rapporteurs spéciaux compétent sur les
différents sujets que nous avons
sélectionné ensemble héééé et par
conséquent s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales
jean germain est il alors s'il n'est pas
il est là pardon il est il et il est
caché au coin si j'ose dire
donc jean germain et pierre jarlier ont
sans doute des sujets de curiosité et
mai
ensuite nous pourrions passer aux
questions relatives au rsa avec éric
bocquet et je ne sais pas si j'ai raoui
gérard miquel est parmi nous donc il y à
un établissement public qui a retenu
l'intérêt de la cour et qui je pense
peut retenir l'intérêt de gérard miquel
et l'onema
ensuite notre rapporteur spécial pour la
culture qui suit la situation et la
relative aisance de trésorerie du centre
des monuments nationaux
yann gaillard aura sans doute à
s'exprimer et d'eux mêmes que sur la
fondation du patrimoine et sans oublier
que la culture est un domaine qui est
suivi par un duo de choc avec aymeri de
montesquiou nous voilà voilà absolument
voilà donc je propose à chacun de ceux
que j'ai cité de bien vouloir interroger
le premier président et les membres de
la cour de le faire naturellement avec
tous leurs soucis habituels de la
concision et donc s'agissant des
collectivités territoriales
lequel d'entre vous dégaine le premier
c'est pierre jarlier alors merci
monsieur le président je voudrais
évoquer la situation des départements
dans votre rapport aux indiqué que les
fonds d'urgence seront insuffisants pour
résoudre leurs difficultés et on ne peut
être que d'accord avec évidemment ce
constat vous avez ok aussi la nécessité
de renforcer la péréquation totalement
au titre ddm t au et de la cvae et vous
proposer d'en revoir les critères là on
ne peut évidemment être aussi que
partager cette nécessité d'autant que
les modalités d'attribution de la
péréquation au tidiane dioh a été on été
considérablement modifié dans la haute
finance 2013 et ont suscité plus qu'une
réelle inquiétude un réel mécontentement
des départements qui étaient
traditionnellement considéré comme
plutôt pauvre
à titre d'exemple on a vu les
bouches-du-rhône hérité de plusieurs
millions d'euros pendant que la creuse
où le cantal en perdaient par exemple 2
alors que le président ma question
portera sur justement les les critères
de définition de richesse de des
départements plus généralement
d'ailleurs des des collectivités ont
fait référence souvent au potentiel
financier ont fait au potentiel fiscal
potentiel financier qui a aussi évolué à
la suite de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle puisque nous avons
intégré dans ce potentiel financier
notamment des compensations voir
certaines compensations virtuel puisque
quotidien fenger certains n'ont jamais
bénéficié de cet argent et donc il y à
d'autres critères aussi comme les
critères de revenus par habitant est ce
que secrétaire de revenu par habitant
est selon-vous d'ailleurs un critère qui
est un indicateur synthétique de charges
comme on l'a utilisé par exemple pour le
bloc pour le bloc local sachant que
malheureusement on y est on l'a ramené
au nombre d'habitants justement dans le
calcul de dante au ski à poser quand
même beaucoup de beaucoup de problèmes
et donc selon vous dans la perspective
de nouvelles restrictions des dotations
de l'état
vous avez évoqué d'ailleurs qu' il
pouvait pas y avoir de solution dans
cette direction qu'est-ce que comment
faudrait-il faire pour pouvoir avoir un
classement de richesse plus objectifs de
ces départements pour mieux établir une
péréquation horizontale entre ces
départements et quels sont les
indicateurs qui vous semblerait donc les
plus pertinents
c'est beaucoup et pierre jarlier la
parole et à jean germain
oui merci monsieur le président donc
vous vous proposer un renforcement fanon
lors de votre présentation du rapport
devant le devant le sénat la cour
considère qu'il existe je la cite des
marges de manoeuvre importantes dans les
communes et les intercommunalités
ce qui est un jugement qui n'est pas
forcément partagée mais qui est
acceptable la proposition que vous
faites de réallouer une partie de la
fiscalité locale entre départements et
bloc communal par un échange entre des
mtv foncier bâti afin de dégager des
marges pour les finances départementales
et elle de la compétence du rapport de
la cour
l'interface est elle pas avec le le
comité des finances locales qui est de
nature constitutionnelle
et si on accepter cette possibilité et
elles conciliables cette proposition
avec la diminution à venir des dotations
qui a été annoncé 1,5 milliard d'euros
par an donc diminution dont le
doublement été annoncé et qui risque de
peser essentiellement sur cet échelon je
rappelle que les collectivités
territoriales réalise une grande part de
l'investissement public français civils
et que donc cette question ne peut pas
être examinée séparément des objectifs
de croissance des objectifs de maintien
de l'emploi des objectifs de création
annuelle de logements
merci beaucoup chers collègues à leurs
questions sur la mission solidarité dans
le rapporteur spécial et notre collègue
éric bocquet
oui merci monsieur le président
effectivement quelques mots sur le rsa
qui est évoquée dans le rapport et qui
rappelle les difficultés que nous avions
nous sommes observés l'an dernier et
cette année à nouveau en matière de
table tout recours notamment
mais cette question est également et a
également été évoqué lors de la
conférence nationale de lutte contre la
pauvreté organisé en en décembre dernier
et avec l'une des décisions prises
concernant le rsa d'une augmentation de
10 % sur les cinq années qui viennent
alors je me posais sur la question de
l'assurance coûte au financement de
cette revalorisation alors que vous
vient de le rappeler les départements
qui ont la charge cette prestation sont
dans des pour beaucoup d'entre eux dans
une très grande précarité financière et
donc une situation très fragile donc
comment cette augmentation programmée
va-t-elle être intégrés géré par
ailleurs dans quelle mesure la cette
revalorisation va concerner également le
rsa activité qui a ses spécificités et
est-ce qu'elle permettra de répondre aux
défis mentionnés dans la partie que vous
consacré au rsa activité dans votre
rapport critiquant notamment son faible
impact sur le taux de pauvreté dans
notre pays
enfin dernier point concernant le rsa
jeunes qui est un dispositif à
l'évidence qui a du mal à décoller il
n'a pas encore réussi à décoller alors
est ce que les constats que vous avez
fait pour le rsa activité sont également
valables pour cette prestation rsa
jeunes ou y at il des raisons
particulières des problèmes spécifiques
qui expliquerait l'échec de cette
prestation
voilà j'ai été très concis
et beaucoup et avec d'autant plus de
mérite que le sujet considérable alors
en remplacement de gérard miquel qui a
dû nous quitter pour le salon de
l'agriculture parce que non mais alors
c'est bien notés pour le tour suivant
donc en remplacement de gérard miquel
monsieur yannick botrel pourrait-il
intervenir sur la politique de l'eau sur
l'onema
pour tout vous dire on me prenais un peu
au dépourvu si c'est plutôt sur d'autres
sujets et que j'aurais souhaité
intervenir mais je n'ai pas de questions
particulières à poser sur le débat dans
tous les cas monsieur vie qu'elle ne m'a
pas laissé d'instructions particulières
écoutez donc et ça sera ça permettra
d'autres collègues de s'exprimer au
second tour si j'ose ainsi m'exprimer
alors nous venons à la culture avec
monsieur yann gaillard et éventuellement
monsieur de montesquiou s'ils le
souhaitent
merci monsieur le président le rapport
public monsieur le premier président
comporte deux assertions relatives à la
politique de protection du patrimoine
la première concerne la fondation du
patrimoine et que vous qualifiez
d'organismes juridiquement hybride
largement financée par des fonds publics
qui utilise une définition intéressante
vous estimez que la fondation a répondu
aux objectifs de sa mission dans la
mesure de ses moyens
selon deux modalités d'action original
et dans des conditions de gestion
satisfaisante
pensez vous que ce modèle singulier
positif serait transposable à d'autres
domaines de la politique publique
vous regrettez néanmoins dans votre
rapport que du fait même de son régime
juridique la dépense publique de la
fondation dans ses diverses actions
restent mal cernés dans son montant est
peu visible dans son fléchage comment
améliorer cette situation selon vous et
notamment l'information à destination du
parlement alors il ya une seconde
assertion qui me paraît plus critique et
qui relèvent des suds donner à votre
contrôle de 2010 sur le centre des
monuments nationaux contrôles réalisés à
la demande de la commission des finances
un autre demande dans le cadre de
l'article 58 de éléments de la laugh
vous estimez que les réformes sont
insuffisantes l'établissement public n'a
pas pris en compte la réforme du régime
de la domanialité publique 2008 la
gestion demeure a suffisamment
rigoureuse absences de contrat est assez
mais niveau de ressources propres trop
peu ambitieux et absent indicateurs de
performance c'est une certitude que vous
jugez préjudiciable qui demeurent dans
le sens d'action du centre des monuments
nationaux et la sous consommation des
crédits d'entretien de restauration
perdure malgré quelques progrès
constatés récemment et croit d'ailleurs
savoir que le responsable du cmn en
quelque sorte pris ses observations
quels sont selon vous aussi le promu
président les pauses cette inertie la
tutelle exerce-t-elle pleinement ses
missions
la réponse de la ministre est elle de
nature à vous rassurer quant à la mise
en oeuvre prochaine des réformes
préconisées à une remobilisation de la
tutelle et s'agissant de la question
comment expliquer l'absence durable de
contrats entre l'état est le centre des
monuments nationaux
que serait selon vous le niveau adéquat
réalise des ressources propres
quelles seraient les indicateurs de
performance les plus pertinents
si beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
spécial jeux de montesquiou et beaucoup
plus brièvement chez le président du
président vous constatez la bonne santé
du cinéma français due en partie jeu au
centre national du cinéma
mais les finances de cet organisme sont
encore plus florissante puis qu'il ya
750 millions de réserves ce qui en
période où les finances sont un peu en
mauvais état nous sommes un peu une
anomalie est ce que vous comptez faire
évoluer le financement du centre
national du cinéma et bien merci
beaucoup monsieur de montesquiou
monsieur le premier président puis-je
vous suggérer de répondre ou de faire
répondre de manière encore plus
synthétique que les questions de
l'enquêté et sachant que tout cela
pourrait bien entendu être complété en
procédure écrite car j'ai pour le second
tour déjà un certain nombre d'inscrits
et je ne voudrais pas qu'ils soient
privés d'intervention
je vais essayer monsieur le président
même si les missions sont lourdes et
nécessite de notre part un certain
nombre de 2,2 de développement alors
tout d'abord pour répondre aux questions
du rapporteur général sur sur dexia et
sur cette coopération
d'abord le traitement de cette opération
en comptabilité nationale ne relève pas
de la compétence de la cour relève de la
compétence de vince est sous le contrôle
de d'euros stats et la cour n'a pas à se
prononcer d'ailleurs sur cette question
qui concerne non seulement la france
mais également la belgique
alors nous avons
toutefois affirmé que l'exercice de
rattachement là serait devant être 2012
en effet le vote de la loi de finances
rectificative qui a ouvert les crédits
nécessaires
l'assemblée générale de dexia qui a
approuvé l'augmentation de capital et le
versement de l'état à dexia ont eu lieu
en décembre 2012
donc ce qui normalement doit permettre
un rattachement à 2012 or si le dossier
de presse du gouvernement envisageaient
la possibilité d'un autre exercice de
rattachement
c'est c'est qu'au moment où ce dossier
de presse a été constitué il n'était pas
totalement sûr que l'opération soit
réalisée avant la fin de l'année je
pense que ça ça explique le décalage qui
a pu y avoir entre l'affirmation de la
cour et puis ceux qui étaient contenues
dans le dossier de presse puisque le
dossier de presse il devait être prêt
pour septembre le jour 2 c'était en loi
de finances rectificative ne s'était
elle est adoptée une certitude
voilà voilà et tout a pu être organisé
dans le mois de décembre
or sur le niveau de déficit public en
nous avons écrit qu' il a
vraisemblablement été proche de
l'objectif à savoir 4,5 pour cent du pig
mais nous avons également noté qu'un
déficit supérieur pouvait ne pas être
exclu en raison de recettes
vraisemblablement plus faibles que prévu
un temps pour l'etac pour la sécurité
sociale
on a pu constater
salma que la commission européenne
retenait pour 2012 une estimation de 4,6
dans toutes ses récentes prévisions
je pense qu'il est difficile sans avoir
les éléments précis d'avoir une idée
plus plus plus précise
le montant du déficit public mesuré
selon les normes de la comptabilité
nationale sera publié par l'insee dans
peu de temps
d'ailleurs la fin du moins de 2 mars
compte tenu du caractère encore fragile
incomplet des informations qui sont
disponibles notamment d'ailleurs sur les
administrations publiques locales en
fonction du résultat sur les
collectivités territoriales
s'il peut y avoir du coup une variation
possible la cour n'a pas souhaité
présenter même sous forme d'une
fourchette une prévision de solde et
administrations publiques s'est contenté
de dire que vraisemblablement serait
proche de l'objectif étant entendu que
on en sera d'autant plus proches si
enfin de dépendra aussi de la décision
prise par les autorités
l'insee et eurostat sur dexia
ça peut là aussi correspondre à de
l'ordre de 0,2 point de de pin
or sur l'objectif de déficit de 3% je ne
reviens pas sur ce que j'ai pu dire tout
à l'heure la cour effectivement par
rapport à l'objectif de soldes effectifs
et à sa réalisation
nous nous avons pu observer que la
poursuite de cet objectif que coûte
pouvait avoir des effets négatifs sur la
croissance trop important lorsque la
conjoncture économique est durablement
mauvaise et que cette situation en plus
est partagé par la plupart des
partenaires économiques de la france en
europe
d'ailleurs on pourrait avoir le même
raisonnement par rapport à un objectif
de déficit et fixiste dans une période
de forte croissance
ça présente aussi des inconvénients
symétrique car l'objectif peut être
atteint
beaucoup plus facilement et sans avoir à
prendre des mesures de redressement dans
une perspective à long terme
donc c'est pour cela que le réseau n'est
seulement en termes de déficit effectif
peu peut ne pas apparaître suffisante et
les européens en sont convenus ce qui
explique le récent traités européens et
donc là la dernière loi organique alors
il ya précisé compte tenu qu'il y a
plusieurs objectifs qui sont mis sur la
table le poids respectif qu'il convient
d'accorder à l'un ou à l'autre
bon ça c'est une décision qui relève des
politiques pourquoi nous avons appelé
justement à cette à cet arbitrage
alors en ce qui concerne les recettes en
2013 pour pour nous les recettes
publiques fiscales et sociales en 2013
bon a priori seront inférieurs aux
prévisions du gouvernement
associé au projet de loi de finances
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord si la
croissance n'est pas au rendez vous dès
08 comme cela semble être le cas
vous le savez pour un demi point de
croissance en moins
les recettes publiques ont réduites de
l'ordre de 4 à 5 milliards d'euros
ce sont bien sûr des ordres de grandeur
donc c'est le premier point
ensuite la prévision pour 2013 repose
sur des élasticités de prélèvements
obligatoires à l'évolution de leur
assiette qui sont vraisemblablement
calculé de façon trop optimistes
notamment pour l'impôt sur les sociétés
est l'enjeu pourrait être de l'ordre là
aussi de 2,4 milliards
deux euros de plus vraisemblablement les
recettes fiscales de 2012 notamment la
tva seront inférieurs aux prévisions ce
qui peut avoir un effet en base donc sur
celle de 2013 c'est encore difficile
d'estimer cela à ce stade mais il en est
vrai seulement de même des recettes des
administrations de sécurité sociale d'où
une nouvelle incertitude
il ya aussi également deux facteurs
d'incertitude qui fragilise les
prévisions de recettes c'est d'une part
le chiffrage des mesures nouvelles
c'est jamais facile à faire et on peut
apercevoir parfois des décalages entre
une estimation et puis la réalité et
puis il y a également le coup en 2013
des contentieux fiscaux communautaire
qui s'impute sur les remboursements et
dégrèvements des recettes fiscales et du
coût réduit les recettes nettes
voilà un peu toutes les incertitudes que
nous avons pu pointer sur les recettes
fiscales
il ya également un élément d'incertitude
pour les recettes non fiscales a aussi
qui sont assez difficiles à évaluer à ce
stade c'est tout ce qui touche aux
recettes non fiscales dividendes des
entreprises publiques
ces dividendes pouvant être inférieur à
la prévision mais là là l'enjeu est une
fois de plus difficile à estimer les
aléas sur les sur les dépenses
il ya ce que j'ai dit sur les
contentieux fiscaux parce qu'il faut
raisonner à la fois en termes de
recettes et 2 et 2 et de dépenses c'est
d'une certaine façon une dépense
à partir du moment où c'est prélevés sur
les recettes
le coût du contentieux relatif au
précompte qui est inscrit dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
comptabilité nationale et de 1,8
milliard d'euros en 2013 après 0
e en 2012 et celui du contentieux sur
les opcvm et de 1,1 milliard en 2013
après un milliard et demi en 2012
pour ce qui concerne le contentieux
relatif au précompte les arrêts du
conseil d'état de décembre 2012
on était en fait plus favorable que que
redouté pour le budget de l'état mais la
direction générale des finances
publiques n'étaient pas en mesure début
février d'en tirer toutes les
conséquences financières pour ce qui
concerne le contentieux relatifs aux
opcm les remboursements effectués en
2012 ont finalement été quasi nulle et
les remboursements prévus en 2012 seront
donc gracieusement reporter en sur 2013
mais ceux prévus en 2013 pourraient de
ce fait aussi être en partie reportés
sur 2014
là nous serons en mesure de vous
apporter des choses plus précises dans
le cadre de notre rapport sur
l'exécution du budget 2012
d'ici le 30 mai prochain on revient un
certain nombre d'aléas sur les dépenses
le principal aller à d'ailleurs repose
sur les dépenses d'indemnisation du
chômage
là il ya un décalage entre l'estimation
de bercy et le montant prévu par
l'unedic et un décalage de l'ordre de 2
milliards d'euros
le gouvernement prévoit 1,8 je crois
alors que l'unedic prévoit une
augmentation supérieure à 8%
d'augmentation bien sûr donc du coup
cette différence de prévisions
représentent de l'ordre de 2 milliards
alors les objectifs de dépenses qui
étaient inscrits dans les rapports
annexés aux branchés loi de finances
dont apparaissait difficile à atteindre
compte tenu de tes informations qu'ils
pouvaient être disponible en septembre
dernier qu'ils le sont encore
aujourd'hui peut-être même davantage à
partir du moment où il ya un prélèvement
supplémentaire de 800 millions d'euros
qui a été ajoutée en loi de finances par
voie d'amendements en faveur de l'union
européenne et où des muses heures
nouvelle non encore budgété ont été
annoncées est susceptible d'avoir des
effets sur 2013 nous pensons aux plans
pauvreté ou au contrat de génération
puis vous avez bien évidemment les
prévisions de dépenses des collectivités
territoriales qui sont toujours
difficiles à établir et fragile il ya un
aléa qui existe mais il faut reconnaître
qu'il est symétrique il peut être à la
hausse ou à la baisse
donc ce que nous avons dit c'est que
compte tenu de ces incertitudes le suivi
de l'exécution des dépenses publiques
nécessitait donc une mue une stricte
vigilance et le cas échéant des mesures
d'ajustement
tout au long de l'année nous aurons
également l'occasion d'y revenir dans
notre rapport de 2 juin sur la situation
et les perspectives des des finances
publiques c'est pour cela que nous avons
dit que il est très important de
concrétiser et respecté l'effort
structurel prévu dans la loi de finances
initiale or après vous
vous avez remis en cause ce que nous
avons pu dire sur le déséquilibre
bon c'est un constat que nous faisons
sur le déséquilibre c'est vrai que d'un
côté il ya 75 % sur les recettes et 25 %
sur les dépenses d'ailleurs ce
déséquilibre il existe depuis le début
en 2011 sur l'effort structurel il a
porté à 100 % en ailleurs sur les
prélèvements obligatoires en 2012 un peu
moins de lors de son contre % et en 2013
c'est à peu près les mêmes ordres de 2,2
de grandeur alors réductions de dépenses
et en plus douloureuses on se trouve
toujours de bonnes excuses
oui pas seulement et puis et puis elles
peuvent avoir un effet moins immédiat en
ce qui concerne bien sûr l'augmentation
des prélèvements obligatoires mort tout
cas c'est peut-être que sur les modèles
macroéconomiques le président raoul
briet pour être apporté quelques
éléments
en fait nos le raisonnement de nous
fondons pas sur des modèles
macroéconomiques parus sur sûr mais dans
ce que sur d'autres pour fonder nos
analyses je vois ça venant signaler sans
rentrer dans le détail technique que les
modèles macroéconomiques ne distingue
pas de manière binaire ski et dépenses
d'un côté ou recettes de l'autre il ya
des effets macroéconomiques de réduction
de certaines dépenses qui sont
équivalents à l'augmentation certains
prélèvements obligatoires gérer une
peser sur les dépenses sociales ou une
augmentation de la csg au maquereau
économiquement et même le même impact
donc j'irai ce n'est pas à travers des
modèles macroéconomiques ou mésanges que
que
la guigne général du discours de la cour
qui est un discours assez constance ce
ce fourbe mais sur un certain nombre
d'autres considérations que premier
président a rappelé tout à l'heure que
je peux peut-être développé vous pouvez
les fondamentalement ce que ce que nous
constatons lots ces deux gars fait avant
nous c'est que les ajustements
budgétaires les plus efficaces et les
plus durables du rhin les plus porteurs
de croissance économique à long terme
sont des ajustements budgétaires qui ont
plutôt porté sur la dépense que sur la
recette c'est une analyse que ces 2 a
fait d'eux de longue date
la deuxième la deuxième remarque c'est
que nous avons un problème de déficit
public
la france aussi à un problème de déficit
de compétitivité que si la compétitivité
ne tient pas qu'à des questions de
prélèvement des questions trouveront
leur place et que donc les marges de
manoeuvre en matière de prélèvements
paraissent des marges de manoeuvre
réduites
et puis troisième élément mais ça a été
rappelé clairement par le premier
président tout à l'heure et ses
arguments essentiels c'est que si on se
compare à certains pays où d'autres pays
des veaux de ces deux il est de fait que
nous avons un niveau de dépenses
publiques
parmi les plus élevés le deuxième au
sein de ses 2 mais que nous n'avons pas
la contrepartie en terme d'efficacité
des politiques publiques à hauteur de
cette deuxième place en termes de
dépenses et que donc il y a à partir de
ce simple constat des espaces pour une
amélioration de l'efficience de la
dépense publique
voilà que je dirais le rationnel qui
sous-tendent la position exprimée
al oui 20 secondes 20 secondes parce que
on a mis en place le haut conseil des
finances publiques est adossé à la cour
des comptes
il est prévu que ceux au kosovo conseil
puisse s'appuyer sur des outils des
modèles économétriques qu'il indique
quels sont les outils auxquels il fait
référence pour donner son analyse
contradictoire
donc cette exigence que j'ai formulées
s'agissant de la vie qui a été émis à
cour des comptes et qui est en
contradiction avec ce qui a été fait par
le gouvernement sur un modèle
économétrique connu appel si on prend un
avis différent à pouvoir s'appuyer sur
des outils prévisionnel fiable et cet
exercice on aura le faire à vos conseils
en l'occurrence mauges anticiper sur
cette exigence en demandant sur quoi
vous fondez pour dire ce que le
gouvernement a fait n'était peut-être
pas ce qui est plus équilibrée et je
indiqué qu'il y avait une volonté
d'équilibrage 55 ans dépenses recettes à
long terme ce qui est dans le sens de ce
que vous disiez mais que à court terme
le modèle maison avait conclu à ce que
l'effet de levier était plus efficace
sur la croissance si on jouait un peu
plus sur les recettes pour démarrer mais
à long terme c'est 55 andré d'accord ça
il conviendra de
le vérifier le haut conseil pourra
effectivement le faire puisque puisque
c'est ce sera pour partie son rôle est
ce que vous avez ce que vous avez
souhaité mais il n'y a pas de ya pas de
contradiction meilleur 1 dans dans ce
qui a été dit par les uns et par et par
les autres sur la durée parce que le
redressement des comptes ils
s'apprécient essentiellement sur sur la
durée et il doit s'apprécier aussi
indépendamment d'une d'une conjoncture
tout en tenant compte bien évidemment de
cette conjoncture
sinon vous souhaitiez que j'aborde une
un sujet avant dernier président si vous
pouviez par égard pour nos collègues qui
sont intervenus répondre ou faire
répondre de manière très synthétique aux
différentes interventions
ça nous permettrait d'engager un second
tour deux questions de garde qu'il y ait
réussi il importe de demandes
d'interventions fait de notre de notre
côté et sachant qu'à partir d'une
certaine heure l'assistance se raréfient
je ne voudrais pas et qu'il y ait des
porteurs de question et qu'ils soient
frustrés de ne pas pouvoir s'exprimer
faucon équilibre entre les défauts
stration possible parce que c'est ici je
ne répondais pas une question d la mort
structurelles et donc voilà juste
répartition des frustrations entre nous
voilà alors sur sur les questions
concernant les les départements bon
c'est pierre jarlier qui a posé cette
question bon le
notre insertion sur sur les départements
montre bien que comme on pouvait s'y
attendre il ya un vrai effet teaser en
fonctionnement avec dépenses réelles de
fonctionnement qui progressent plus vite
que les recettes réelles qui stagnent
les dépenses sociales voit bien sur leur
poids continué de s'accroître
elle représente à elle seule un peu plus
la moitié des charges réelles de
département et on le voit bien au niveau
des recettes de droits de mutation à
titre onéreux
elle diminuerait de 800 millions d'euros
en 2012 alors qu'elle avait fortement
très fortement augmenté en 2011 1 par
rapport à 2010 aurillac paris qui
échappent semble-t-il à ce mouvement de
baisse pour des raisons qui peuvent
parfaitement se comprend l'épargné brute
qui avait progressé entre 2009 et 2011
décroît maintenant et dans des
proportions sensiblement 5,55 pour cent
et en investissement le mouvement de
contraction se poursuit je crois que
c'est un d'entre vous qui faisait
observer que ses dépenses
d'investissement se seront repliées de
près de 2 19% au total en trois ans ce
qui concerne les départements
donc je dirais que que les chiffes de
2012 conforte confirme les analyses que
nous avions pu faire alors sur la
péréquation départemental je vous
donnerai la parole à si vous le voulez
bien à jean-philippe vacas sur la
redistribution des ressources contre
niveaux de collectivités je voudrais
dire à jean germain que la proposition
que que nous formulons d'un transfert de
droits de mutation à titre onéreux des
départements vers le bloc communal
en contrepartie du transfert d'une part
de la taxe sur le foncier bâti du bloc
communal vers les départements
ce réaménagement n'a pas du tout pour
objet de diminuer les ressources du bloc
communal
devrait être équilibré il part de de
l'idée qu'il peut être utile d'augmenter
la part modulable de la fiscalité des
départements puisque on le voit bien ce
qui concerne les départements la
fiscalité indirecte représentent une
proportion importante de pratiquement
plus de 50 pour cent cinquante deux pour
cent
et donc si on leur donne la possibilité
de jouer sur 7 sur ses droits de
mutation ça ne peut que renforcer leurs
capacités en termes de ressources
fiscales sans remettre en cause sans
remettre en cause je dirais le le le la
part des ressources fiscales du bloc
communal qui je le rappelle est composée
à plus de 90% de fiscalité directe quand
on raisonne à long terme
on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
dynamique ddm théo qui peut être plus
avantageuse pour le bloc communal
donc une fois de plus c'est le
réaménagement de la fiscalité proposé
par la cour ne tend pas à réduire les
marges budgétaires du secteur communal
mais à stabiliser l'évolution des
ressources fiscales des départements
c'est l'objectif
alors quelle est la légitimité de la
cour a formulé ce type de proposition
une fois de plus nous ne décidons rien
mais nous formulons à partir du moment
où effectivement au niveau de la cour et
les chambres régionales il peut y avoir
une capacité d' expertise à partir des
contrôles que nous faisons nous
permettons de mètres des pistes sur la
table étant entendu que c'est le
parlement qui qui en décident il n'y a
pas du tout je lui dirais de concurrence
avec le comité des finances locales
puisque l'émission ne sont pas
pas les mêmes sur la péréquation
départementale contenus dans philippe
valcq à peut répondre à la question qui
a été posée
oui il est clair que dans la situation
de contrainte où se trouve placé les
départements
l'une des voies que nous avons proposées
dans le rapport c'est le renforcement de
la péréquation qui n'est pas du tout
négligeable d'ores et déjà notamment à
travers le fonds de péréquation ddmt au
alors à ce moment-là on bute très vite
et vos débats en ont été la preuve sur
le concept de potentiel fiscal de
potentiel financier
la définition est la même mais la
composition se transforme profondément
et donc on aboutit à des différences de
classement qui sont producteurs des
faits non non nécessairement désiré
lorsque nous nous ne nous n'avons pas de
propositions à faire sur une nouvelle
définition ou une nouvelle composition
et potentiel financier du potentiel
fiscal ce que nous disons c'est que
vraisemblablement et plus encore
aujourd'hui qu'hier mais ça ne suffit
plus comme référentiel comme critère de
redistribution des ressources entre les
collectivités alors dans le cas des
départements
il y à la montée en puissance
effectivement du critère du revenu
nous avons vu ce qui a été fait
notamment l'occasion de la loi de
finances pour 2013 s'agissant notamment
du fonds dmt haut au delà on ne peut pas
ne pas remarquer que la répartition des
critères n'est pas exactement la même
pour les dm théo et la cvae
je parle des deux fonds de péréquation
qui de toute façon ne sont pas du même
ordre de grandeur
après nous ce qui nous semble par
rapport aux études que nous avons faites
département par département c'est nous
pensons que il ya la troisième la
troisième série de critères c'est à dire
le revenu certes mais au delà les
critères véritablement de charge et
notamment pour les départements les
charges on sait concerne les allocations
universelles de solidarité qui doit
pouvoir être recoupée je dirais avec les
situations financières des départements
qui sont très variable d'un département
à l'autre et c'est en croisant ces
critères que l'on peut déterminer des
niveaux de fragilité c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans notre dans notre rapport
donc nous avons nous n'avons pas de
formules toutes faites à proposer il
faut que la dgcl face au marché ces
modèles
mais notre conviction c'est que
véritablement maintenant il faut donner
une part plus importante aux critères de
revenus et de charges dans les
mécanismes de péréquation temps
péréquation verticale traditionnels que
là les mécanismes en développement de
péréquation horizontale dans nous
voudrions qu'elle se développe sur le
rsa rapidement il ya un os du barème du
rsa qui est annoncée dans le plan
quinquennal de lutte contre la pauvreté
bien évidemment cette hausse du vam ont
un effet sur toutes les composantes du
rsa tout cela ça socle du rsa activité
le rsa jeunes qui constitue en fait une
seule et même prestation
pour ce qui concerne le volet l'état ce
que l'on peut constater un s'agissant du
du rsa c'est qu'en fait il y a beaucoup
moins de personnes qui en bénéficient
par rapport à ceux qui seraient
susceptibles d'en bénéficier
concrètement pour ça qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs une meilleure articulation
entre ce dispositif de rsa et la ppe et
on invite les pouvoirs publics à avoir
cette réflexion pour ce qui concerne
plus particulièrement le
rsa socle qui était une des questions
posées qui lui est à la charge des
départements c'est bien qu'aucune comme
aucune estimation officielle n'a été
communiquée à la cour celle ci pourrait
représenter notamment la la
revalorisation qui a été annoncé par le
premier ministre un coût supplémentaire
de l'ordre de 180 millions d'euros en
année pleine
le premier ministre a indiqué que ce
coût serait compensé par l'état
mais les modalités de financement n'ont
pas encore été semble-t-il en tout cas
définitivement arrêté on n'a pas
d'information à ce sujet s'il n'y avait
pas de compensation c'est sûr qu'il y
aurait une dégradation du taux de
couverture de la charge liée aux grès à
supporter par les départements et donc
du coup une tension accrue sur les
finances départementales mais il n'y a
aucune raison de mettre en doute la
parole de l'état en l'occurrence en ce
qui concerne en ce qu'ils font mais nous
ne pouvons le constater qu'à postériori
bon il n'y a pas de raison de le
constater a priori c'est le bon sinon
bon sur le rsa
activité comme pour le rsa jeunes c'est
ont fait les mêmes constats c'est à dire
qu'il ya un nombre de bénéficiaires
extrêmement réduit par rapport au
potentiel de deux candidats possibles en
compte tenu d'une trop grande complexité
il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui
expliquent que le les dispositifs de ne
ne sont pas complètement opérationnel et
là ça rejoint ce que j'ai pu dire par
rapport à vraiment une réflexion qu'il
faut conduire sur une meilleure
articulation entre tous les dispositifs
et notamment rsa et ppe
bon c'est pas la première fois que la
cour le 10 et nous leur disons une vous
invitons à ces évaluations le plus
rapidement possible sur la protection du
du patrimoine avec la fondation du
patrimoine
et puis le centre des monument national
d'émotion peut-être que le président le
fa pourrait apporter les événements vous
souhaitez connaissant bien parce que
nous avons vrai ensemble sur absolument
type de ce monsieur le président on donc
sur la fondation du patrimoine le
rapporteur spécial et yann gaillard a
tout à fait raison de souligner qu' il
s'agit d'un être juridiquement hybride
nous nous avons qualifié cela de modèles
de modèle singulier dans la mesure où il
s'agit d'une en fait d'une fondation
donc de stature de statut privé qui a
été décidé par la loi est placée sous le
contrôle de la de la cour des comptes
donc c'est une histoire déjà un peu
ancienne puisque la création date de
1996 organismes original aussi par le
fait qu' il a une gouvernance qui laisse
les responsabilités dans la main des
fondateurs qui depuis leur mise initiale
non plus apporté de cotisation de
cotisation additionnelle
et puis elle délivre des désagréments de
la belle fondation du patrimoine et la
deux
2003 c'est vous d'ailleurs qui les
premiers la vie et décide et une
recettes domaniales affecté qui sont le
produit des successions en déshérence
donc c'est un c'est un modèle assez
assez original et qui représente donc
comme vous le savez pas ce que c'est un
sujet qui va vous concerner directement
- pour pour avis quand le gouvernement
présentera à l'automne prochain la le
projet de loi sur sur les patrimoines
c'est donc le volet non protégés c'est à
dire tout ce qui n'est pas le monument
historique donc c'est en fait là la
grande majorité puisque c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers de biens et le
résultat pratique entre 2002 et 2011 est
tout de même assez spectaculaire puisque
la fondation a soutenu plus de 18000
projet de rénovation dont quatorze mille
privé et 4 me public donc c'est une
source que vous que vous avez su au
niveau local eut utilisé alors est-ce
que ce modèle singulier transposable à
l'action publique c'était l'action
publique
alors la première que partie de de la
question c'est au fait de savoir si
c'est transposable aux monuments
historiques c'est peut-être la première
question que vous alors ça on verra ce
qui ce qu'il en est ce qui est sûr c'est
que le problème des modes des monuments
historiques c'est qu'on en en classe
chaque année le maire supplémentaires
400 donc qui sont soit portée à
l'inventaire donc compétences régionales
soient nationales et donc avec à la clé
tous les avantages fiscaux représentant
autre pour les travaux de la station et
les obligations fasse raison je de
sécurité de devoir faire intervenir la
collectivité et publics collectivités
territoriales ou ou est un donc je ne
sais pas ce que le gouvernement
présentera dans tout état de cause pour
le moment ce modèle est bien délimité et
a produit incontestablement un effet un
effet positif l'outil fondation est
utilisé dans d'autres domaines d'action
d'action publique notamment dans tout ce
qui est
la partie scientifique l'école et
fondation de coopération scientifique et
puis il ya bien sûr les fondations
partenariales pour le centre des
monuments nationaux
votre alors oui il y avait aussi la
question sur comment améliorer
l'information à destination du du
parlement dès lors qu'il y a une recette
affecté c'est légitime que la
représentation nationale en soit
informée sur les conditions dans
lesquelles elle est utilisée et donc qui
est plus d'informations sur cette
fondation nous paraît nécessaire sur le
centre des monuments nationaux
alors là c'est aussi un sujet que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous aviez
demandé un votre commission avait
demandé un rapport en 2010 salle qui
vous a été remis à l'automne 2010 et
nous en assurons le suivi
nous sommes effectivement critiques sur
le temps qui a été perdue depuis depuis
2010 pour un ensemble de raisons qui
doivent être met en cause la tutelle
mais aussi la direction générale de
l'établissement
vous avez signalé que le gouvernement
n'avait tiré par anticipation les
conséquences puisque on a maintenant un
nouveau président et qui d'ailleurs
l'ancien directeur général des
patrimoines donc les conséquences je
pense en son nom sont tirés après la la
question qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
que c'est un c'est un modèle qui assure
la mutualisation est donc le moment venu
quand vous posez les grands de savoir
s'il faut reprendre le mouvement qui
avait été amorcé le transfert aux
collectivités territoriales de nouveaux
monuments nationaux la question c'est en
réalité de savoir comment mutualiste de
façon à assurer le financement des des
travaux de restauration
alors incontestablement dans tous les
établissements publics culturels c'est
celui qui a le niveau de ressources
propres le plus élevé 1
il faut donc continuer puisque il y à
des sources d'économies possibles au
travers dans les établissements
culturels de l'augmentation des
ressources propres
donc les visiteurs et il faut aussi
qu'ils consomment les crédits ce qui
vaut ce qu'ils entreprennent seulement
de faire avec le premier travail de
restauration qui va être le dôme du
panthéon c'est en fait le premier
travail est ce que tous les problèmes
qui avaient retardé les choses s'étaient
notamment la crise la crise interne mais
aussi les compétences transfert
d'emplois entre les drac et le centre
des monuments nationaux et également les
problèmes de domanialité de domanialité
publique
donc il y a là un sujet pour
d'interrogation pour l'avenir
quant à la question du dessinateur et
monuments et skew elle ne fait pas
partie de notre sur le sur le cinéma
elle ne fait pas partie de notre rapport
annuel où j'étais venu de vendre votre
commission ce prénom vous y avait fait
allusion le rapport 58,2 sur le
financement du cnc
nous continuons à travailler vous le
gouvernement à tirer les conséquences
puisque le fonds de roulement a été
amputé ébréché il en reste effectivement
un volet important
nous venons de terminer nous avons eu la
réponse donc je peux en faire état le
contrôle du fonds de garantie qui
étaient versés chaque année à l'issic
donc lassitude financement qui joue un
rôle évidemment important dans le pré
financement des productions toute la
partie en fait risque de fabrication des
films et productions audiovisuelles et
la conséquence pratique qui est de
résultant de notre contrôle c'est qu' il
n'y aura plus de versement du fonds de
garantie parce que ils sont arrivés un
étiage suffisant donc là ça fait des
économies pour le cnc est donc peut-être
des pistes d'économies ultérieure donc
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faudra que
nous y revenions il faudra clairement
que nous y revenions
nous travaillons sur un rapport public
thématique ce qui couvrira l'ensemble
des problématiques de soutien les
crédits d'impôts les obligations d'achat
les obligations réglementaires et tout
ce qui est lié la chronologie des médias
et puis bien sûr le cnc et les aides aux
collectivités territoriales puisque sur
plusieurs raisons nous avons fait d un
certain nombre de contrôles
si infiniment monsieur le premier
président et mesdames et messieurs les
les présidents et membres de la cour
alors je passe la parole à monsieur
christian bourquin monsieur premier
président pour pour la sortie de crise
qui nous préoccupe beaucoup à tous comme
de nombreuses voix d'experts le monde de
l'économie
que ce soit en france ou en europe qui
nous disent que c'est en investissant
qu'on sortira de la crise
c'est le premier constat que je voulais
faire en prenant la parole deuxième j'ai
suivi comme mes collègues vos
déclarations pour redresser les comptes
beaucoup sont apparues dans la presse et
vous recommander d'aller encore plus
d'élan vers l'austérité
sur le terrain la traduction de cela
s'apparenterait à une purge au point où
une année hors venez de nous le dire
tout à l'heure j'ai bien noté le niveau
vous lis toujours le niveau de la
dépense publique est élevé vous y
associer les dépenses des collectivités
territoriales or dans la dépense
publique qui il y à l'investissement et
vous ne semblez pas le laisse terminer
comme cible ou comme pot de fleur a
arrosé ou de moins fleur arrosée dans le
jardin vous n'êtes pas allé jusqu'au
cela jusque là et cela me trouble assez
au sens où chacun le sait plus de 110 %
de l'investissement public en france et
fait par les collectivités territoriales
j'y suis d'autant plus sensible que tu
as moins président d'une région
j'ai mené mon budget à l'investissement
jusqu'à 44 % cette année c'est dire que
on peut miser fortement sur
l'investissement pour sortir de la crise
alors ma question c'est comment cela
vous interpelle ce différentiel d'
analyse qui lie entre des experts qu'il
faut entendre leur voix aujourd'hui est
ce que vous semblez dire sur cette cette
façon de sortir de la crise par plus
plus d'austérité dit à christian
bourquin la parole est à jean-claude
fréquents
oui monsieur le président je serais très
court que le premier président vous
n'avez pas parlé dans votre rapport tout
au moins lorsque j'en avais vu jusqu'à
maintenant je n'ai pas et je n'ai pas vu
consulter tout le gros programme de
camps nous avait donné tout à l'heure je
ne vous ai pas entendu parler des
engagements hors bilan de l'état qui est
pourtant qu'une dépense importante dans
le budget alors c'est vrai que nous vous
avons demandé un rapport au titre du
58,2 que vous devez nous présenter début
mais c'est peut-être la raison pour
laquelle vous en parlez pas dans le
rapport d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
important je voudrais donc savoir où
est-ce que vous en êtes de ceux de cette
préparation de rapports
on avait prévu que vous pourriez nous
donner début mais je voudrais vous
signaler que début mai c'est la période
de vacances du sénat mais naturellement
nous serons présents si vous versez près
à ce moment là mais est ce que vous
pourriez nous donner un peu plus
précisément une date
merci sénat est à la disposition de la
république il est prêt à renoncer à
toutes ses vacances pour comprendre les
engagements hors bilan
alors monsieur francis delattre monsieur
premier président d'abord une
observation est une question l'opération
vous dire qu'ils sont quand même
quelques uns ici la commission un
partage et de ne pas avoir partagé à
l'époque
l'analyse du rapporteur général sur la
croissance nous ne croyons pas forcément
tous les modèles économétriques mais
quand même
prélever plus de 1% prélèvements
essentiellement majoritairement sur les
entreprises nous ne pensions pas que ça
pouvait produire une croissance de 0,8
et nous avions même dit qu'on serait
plus proche de zéro que de 0,8 le c'est
à cette analyse a été largement conforté
par la mise en place du financement du
crédit d'impôt pour les entreprises pour
pallier la compétitivité qui du coup
s'aggravait encore avec les prélèvements
qu'elles ont subies alors sur ce
prélèvement deux questions la première
c'est que le défaut nous sommes d'accord
il faut alléger les charges des
entreprises
mais le premier défaut c'était que pour
c'était pratiquement neutre donc on
d'ailleurs on dit crédit d'impôt aux
termes n'est même plus approprié puisque
majorité des entreprises n'auront pas
d'impôts payés alors la question est de
savoir si vous pensez comme nous croient
le dispositif n'est pas ne s'appliquera
pas mais un ministre nous a dit que la
banque la bip allait intervenir
est-ce que vous pensez que la banque
d'investissement c'est son job
le faire
oui la banque pour investissement c'est
son job de faire des enfants c'est ce
qu'elle va faire des chèques aux
entreprises
ça nous paraît quand même assez curieuse
le système voilà pour l'audition de
didier migaud le premier président de la
cour des comptes
ils étaient entendus sur le rapport
annuel de la cour qui a été rendu public
le 12 février vous pourrez revoir cette
audition à tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne matinée à tous
sur public sénat